[موسيقى]
يذكر المؤرخون انه لم يكن في خزانته
الشخصيه ما يكفي من المال لتكاليف جنازته
فالدينار الواحد والدراهم السبعه
والاربعون التي كانت فيها لا تشتري كفنه
بعد ان انفق معظم ماله في الصدقه انه
القائد الاسلامي الكبير السلطان الناصر
صلاح الدين الايوبي محرر القدس من احتلال
الصليبيين الذي دام لاكثر من 90 عاما في
مثل هذه الايام توفي صلاح الدين ومنذ ذلك
الحين لم تنجب الامه ويصلح لها الدنيا
والدين
الى العناوين
كم يشتري راتب الموظف المصري من اللحمه
وهل الفقراء اسعد من الاغنياء
اليونسف تبحث شؤون الطفوله السعيده مع
النظام السوري
دونالد ترامب يعد الناخبين الامريكيين
بمنع الحرب العالميه
نزل نتنياهو يصف المتظاهرين الاسرائيليين
ضد ابيه بالارهابيين
افريقيا تهينو ماكرون مجددا وتلقنه درسا
سينساه كالعاده
زعيم مجموعه يمينيه في استراليا يعلن
اسلامه بعدما كان يهاجم المساجد
مستشار الحلبوسي يعلده مرجعيه دينيه جديده
مقدسه في العراق
[موسيقى]
مرحبا راتب الموظف المصري العادي كم يشتري
اليوم من اللحمه في لبنان يشتري كيلو
واحدا اما في مصر فيشتري كيلو وفوقه نصف
الكيلو يبقى افضل من لبنان بفارق 500 غرام
لحمه اضافيه بحسابات النائب ضياء داوود
انا النهارده اسره المصريه اللي بتاخد
خمسه واتنين من عشره مليون
قطر بت
كيف ما درت وجهك وما يبقى معك شي مليم
تخاف عليه ولو عندك قلقان اكتر المفلس
شويه لكن عايش كل شيء مبسوط احسن ما عندوش
الحسبه
خالد الجندي استبدل قاف الفقر بالخاء ودعا
الفقراء الى الشعور بالفخر وليس الفقر
فالفقر جميل وكلما ازداد ازداد معه الفخر
اللهم اجعل عبدك خالد الجندي فخورا اني
ايام الصعوبه وايام قله المال وايام
الاحتياج كانت بتثير الفخر لانها عدت عليك
من غير ما تجرح قلبك من غير ما تحطم نفسك
من غير ما تخدش كرامتك من غير ما تقتل فيك
عزه نفسك ولا يا خالد في ناس المال ومش
الفقر بيخدش كرامتهم وكثره المال بتقتل
فيهم عزه نفسهم وانت ادرى
المشهد بنظارات رئيس الوزراء مصطفى مدبولي
مختلف تماما فالشكوى على الحكومه هي من
كثره انجازاتها وليس من قلتها والمنصفون
بميزانه يقولون له خفوا السرعه شويه في
الانجازات والمشاريع حجم الدوله المصريه
ويمكن احيانا يعني اسمحوا لي احنا يعني
كنا بنتابع على المدار الفتره اللي فاتت
ان في ناس كثيره مستكتره حجم الشغل اللي
بيتعمل في البلد وبتقول يعني طب يعني هدوا
بس شويه السرعه ويعني يعني يعني خففوا
شويه العمليه لان حجم العمل وحجم الجهد
وحجم طبعا الانفاق على هذه المشروعات يعني
ممكن يكون كبير عضو مجلس الشيوخ المصري
فريده النقاش
ذهبت الى المربع الاسهل لتحديد سبب غلاء
الاسعار اصابع خفيه اخوانيه وسلفيه فريده
النقاش شخصيه نيابيه مسجد الشيوخ عرفت
بمصطلحاتها النابيه وليس النيابيه
بالمصطلحات السوقيه التي لا تليق بالمشاهد
المصري الكريم ولا بامراه في العقد التاسع
من عمرها حضرتك وصفتي بعض الصحفيين
والمثقفين اللي تعاملوا مع جماعه الاخوان
بانهم يمارسون البغاء المقنع
يعني اه قلت كده
رئيسه فريده وكيلو مجلس الشيوخ بهاء ابو
شقه ذهب الى الحلول العمليه بعيدا عن
الاتهامات والصفصه فحضروا انفسكم ايها
المغتربون المصريون لهذا الاقتراح ابو شقه
يريد تخصيص نسبه اجباريه من رواتبكم لصالح
دولتكم التي ربتكم وعلمتكم رداءه الفيلم
من المصدر اما رداءه الفكره فايضا من
المصدر
محدده محاكمه
يكون هناك بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
مئويه مما يحصل عليه
من سوريا اقتراح ارقى من اقتراح ابو شقه
الاقتراح لا يقضي بالصفو على رواتب الناس
بل على بيوتهم وبالقوه تاميم المنازل
الفارغه او الحلول التي يجب ان نعمل عليها
اولا
قانون استملاك لجميع لجميع الشقق الفارغه
كل من يملك شقتين كل من يملك شقتين عليه
انه يتبرع بوحده او يبيع وحده او يتنازل
عن وحده قانون يحكم اسمك هو الاستملاك
ورفع عام فيما كان البرلمان السوري منعقضا
ومحيطه يشهد ورشه عمل لاطفال يبحثون عن
شيء ياكلونه في القمامه كانت منظمه
اليونيسيف تبحث في دمشق شؤون الطفوله
السعيده مع النظام السوري وقد بحث المقداد
مع كاسر راسلا المديره التنفيذيه لمنظمه
الامم المتحده لل طفوله اليونيسف التعاون
القائمه بين سوريا والمنظمه في مختلف
المجالات المقداد اكد الاهميه التي توليها
سوريا للاطفال وحقوقهم الطبيعيه
ليس فقط بالمدنيين ولكن هناك الكثير من
لبوا النداء ورموا السلاح لان هناك فعلا
عفو كبير كان قادم
الرئيس بشار حافظ الاسد الله يخليلنا
بالروح بالدم نفديك يا بشار هذه التمثيليه
التلفزيونيه الفاشله لم تكن في حينه
اجتهادا ذاتيا من الاعلام السوري الرسمي
بل انه مسار طبعًا معظم الاعلام العربي
الرسمي ومنذ عقود ويقوم على سياسه
البرافدا
تعني باللغه الروسيه الحقيقه وهي الصحيفه
السوفييتيه التي كان لدين احد مؤسسيها
وكان دورها ان تعبر بالكامل عن افكار
الحزب الشيوعي ورغباته بلغه خشبيه لا تهتم
براي الناس وبمدى تقبلهم لخطابها مع مفعول
رجعي ذهب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الى الهند
ليخبرهم ان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
سنه على روسيا وليس العكس فضحك الجمهور
وصدم لافروف وعاشت البرافدا ظهور
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب لا
يبتعد كثيرا عن تحميل واشنطن مسؤوليه ما
يجري فبعد ان قدم نفسه خبيرا متخصصا في كل
شيء من سر خلطه الكنتاكي الى القنبله
النوويه اعتبر انه المرشح الرئاسي الوحيد
القادر على انقاذ الولايات المتحده من
الديمقراطيين الحربيين ومن الجمهوريين
المتعصبين الاغبياء لقد تعهد بمنع الحرب
العالميه الثالثه خلال يوم واحد اذا
اعادته الانتخابات الرئاسيه الى البيت
الابيض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مصطلحوا الارهاب ثبت انه رخو وبدون محددات
ومعايير لم يعد له بريق يعني يتبهدل
واشنطن وحلفاؤها ارهابيون في تقييم النائب
رئيس مجلس الامن القوميه الروسي
واضافها ان الولايات المتحده بريطانيا
فرنسا والمانيا تشارك في الاعمال
الارهابيه التي يرتكبها نظام كييف يا اير
بنيامين نتنياهو بلا صغرى وصف المتظاهرين
ضد سياسات ابيه بالارهابيين بعد حصارهم
سلميا صالون التزيين الذي كانت والدته
ساره تصفف شعرها فيه تزامنا مع التظاهرات
للمعارضه وبعد ثلاث ساعات من الحصار
استطاعت قوه كبيره من الشرطه اخراجها ساره
من صالون التجميل اسرائيل تتجه نحو شارع
مقابل شارع وتظاهره مقابل تظاهره وفي نفس
الساحات فهل اقتربت المواجهه امرارا
للتظاهرات التي تجرى اسبوعيا احتجاجا على
التغييرات الجذريه التي تحاول الحكومه
اجراؤها في الجهاز القضائي والان الشرطه
رصدت على شبكه الانترنت ومواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي محاولات لتنظيم تظاهرات مضاده
لتلك التظاهرات وفي نفس المواقع وزير ما
يسمى بالامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار بن
كبير لا يريد هدنه صلب لقد اصدر تعليمات
لشرطه الاحتلال في القدس بفتح ورشه هدم
منازل الفلسطينيين حتى خلال شهر رمضان
المبارك
فهل تتدخل واشنطن الولايات المتحده قاطعت
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي بالامس بعد دعوته
الشهيره لمحو قريه حوار الفلسطينيه
غريب ان تقاطع واشنطن ما يدعو الى محو
قريه حواره والا تقاطع عمليا من يمحو
احياء في غزه كحي الرمال الذي دمره القصف
الجوي الاسرائيلي قبل اقل من عامين ووصفته
الصحافه الاجنبيه بانه تعرض لما يشبه
الزلزال غريب ايضا الا ترى واشنطن ان
المستوطنين باتوا ينافسون افلام هوليوود
في غارات السطو والاحراق لبيوت
الفلسطينيين في حواره وغيرها كانت اسوء
ليله في الليالي جميعها
الاربع جحاطه عن الاسوار عن السور خلعوا
البوابه خلعوا الاسواق
حرقوا الباب صاروا يضربوا فينا افتحوا
البوات افتحوا الابواب مشان ايش
من شان يحرقونها بدهم يحرقونا واحنا نعيط
عرب
امريكا تعالوا شوفونا عروض جديده من
الاوروبيين للفلسطينيين كل ضحيه تسقط منكم
سنرسل من يعزي بها وفد اوروبي يقدم في
قريه زعتر التعازي لعائله الشهيد الشيخ
سامح الاقطس الذي ذهب الى تركيا لمساعده
ضحايا الزلزال ثم عاد الى فلسطين لتقتله
اسرائيل الوفد الاوروبي قال ان استشهاد
الاقطش حدث حزين خاصه بعد عودته من انقاذ
واغاثه المتضررين جراء الزلز ال الذي ضرب
تركيا
باتجاه المناطق اللي فيها الزلزال راحوا
طبعا يساعدوا ويوزعوا المواد التمويليه
والاغاثيه يساعد الناس اللي تضررت هناك
قبل اسبوع روح من تركيا على فلسطين
[موسيقى]
تاريخنا المشترك هنا في الجابون هو ايضا
جزء من تاريخ افريقيا الفرنسيه لكن تلك
الحقبه قد ولت راضيا بالقسمه والنصيب يعلن
ايمانويل ماكرون نهايه افريقيا الفرنسيه
وذلك بعد طرد قواته من غير بلد افريقي
وافراس سلسله اهانات له توجها رئيس
الجمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه فيليكس
تشيسيكيدي الذي احرج ماكرون مباشره على
الهواء وطلب منه مواقف محترمه تحترم
افريقيا ولا تمارس عليها دور الوصايه ماده
اصبعه نحو ماكرون وقال له انظروا الينا
باحترام ام بدون املاءات افريقيا ليست
ابنتكم كلمات قاسيه ولاذعه وضعت الرئيس
الفرنسي في موقف لا يحسد عليه الذي جاء
الى افريقيا لتصحيح المسار بعد الطرد
فرنسا من عده بلدان افريقيه جاء وك يملك
هذه البلاد بطولها وعرضها لكنه اصطدم
برايس الثاني اكبر دوله افريقيه فبدا
امامه وكانه دبلوماسي متدرب لا يفقه
السياسه اعتقد انه يجب ان يسود الاحترام
في نظرتنا لبعضنا البعض يجب ان يحدث تغيير
في تعاوننا مع فرنسا واوروبا انظروا الينا
بطريقه مختلفه فيها احترام لنا واعتبرونا
شركاء حقيقيين لا تنظر الينا دائما نظره
ابويه مع فكره انكم تعرفون دائما ما يصلح
لنا عندليب الاليزيه ماكرون متخبط كما
يوصف جاب البهدله ايضا لوزير خارجيته
الذي استخدم مؤخرا افريقيا مثالا لسوء
السياسه والحكم والاداره عندما يطرح صحفي
او صحفيه فرنسيه سؤالا فهذا لا يعني
الحكومه الفرنسيه
انا اشير الى تصريحاتي هو يعبر عن الموقف
الرسمي الفرنسي عباره التوافقات على
الطريقه الافريقيه تعود وليس للصحفيه
افريقيا لقنت ماكرون درسا سينساه حتما
براي بهيج لان ماكرون مثلا لم يستفد من
امكانيه فرصه احتوائه غضب نحو مليارين
مسلم منه ومن جمهوريته التي اباحت قيمها
الاساءات المتكرره لدين الاسلام ولنبيهم
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم كذلك لم يعالج
ماكرون ذاكره المظلوميه الجزائريه
والروانديه التاريخيه كما وعد على يد
جمهوريته التي تحتفظ وغيرها من دول
اوروبيه
بجماجم ضحاياها المسلمين والافارقه عديد
المتاحف الاوروبيه لا تزال تحتفظ بعشرات
الالاف من الرفاه البشريه ومنها متحف
الانسان في باريس الذي يحتوي على 18 الف
جمجمه يعود عدد منها الى الحقبه
الاستعماريه
بث التلفزيون التركي تقريرا يتهم الكنيسه
الاسبانيه بسعي لاخفاء الهويه الاسلاميه
لمسجد قرطبه واستبدالها باخرى مسيحيه وذلك
من خلال خطه تقضي ببناء مركز زوار في
المسجد لتصحيح ما وصفته الكنيسه بالرؤيه
الاسلاميه المبالغ بها وفق ما نقلته صحيفه
ذات تايمز البريطانيه وانتقد الكاهن
الكاثوليكي الاسباني ديمتريو فيرنانديز ما
وصفه بالصبغه الثقافيه الاسلاميه القويه
لمدينه قرطبه هذا الكاهن ذكرنا بالصحفيه
الفرنسيه التي انتقد واستغرب كثره المساجد
في الدوحه هنا
والاخ ديمتريو منزعج من الطراز الاسلامي
الواضح للمساجد المساجد هي الطراز
الاسلامي بعينه مطاعم ماكدونالدز
[موسيقى]
بعد 14 عاما قضاها في التعرف على الاسلام
لانتقاده وللتهجم عليه اعلنا القصر
والكاهن الكاثوليكي الامريكي الشهير
هيلاريون هيجي اعلن اسلامه بعدما وصفه
برحله البحث التي انتهت في اللحظه
المناسبه وقد اختار اسما اسلاميا وعربيا
لنفسه فصار سعيد عبد اللطيف وسط تفاعل
واسع من المتابعين اكانوا مؤيدين لخطوته
او رافضين كالمبشر الارثوذكسي مشان لوفتين
كان يعتبر اشهر المعادين للمسلمين في
استراليا على الاطلاق تراس جماعه يميديه
متطرفه يعرف عن نفسه وع اتباعه فيها بانهم
يجمعون بين التشددين الديني والقومي وقد
قاد احتجاجات تمكنت من منع بناء المسلمين
مسجدا لهم في احدى المناطق باستراليا
اشهر المعادين للمسلمين في استراليا يعتنق
الاسلام ويتهم البروباجندل الاعلاميه
الغربيه والاسرائيليه بتضليله
[موسيقى]
ملك المغرب محمد السادس لم يعد اميرا
للمؤمنين المغاربه فقط فقد اعلنته وزيره
الخارجيه السنغاليه
امر المؤمنين الملك محمد السادس عاهر
المغرب هو امير المؤمنين ايضا بالسنغال
وارغب كسنغاليين مسلمين ان نعبر عن
احتراماتنا لامير المؤمنين جلاله الملك
محمد السادس
ظهور مرجعيه مقدسه جديده في العراق هو
رئيس البرلمان محمد الحلبوسي يعلن عن
تطويبه هاديا للناس الى الجنه احد
مستشاريه الشخصيين الحلبوسي نفسه مصدع
اليوم الانبار حقيقه انا بالنسبه الي
اليوم نجيب اسم سياده الرئيس الحلبوسي
اقول له اتوضا لان هذا الرجل مقدس راح
تقول لي شنو مقدس راح اقول لك مقدس
بالنسبه لاهل الانبار وبعض من وضع بعض من
مناطق بغداد والعراق
مقدس لان هو بعد النار
عن اهله وداهم للجنه رئيس احد المجالس
النيابيه الليبيه كما يوصف عقيل صالح يعمل
بالمفرق ويتبدل كما الطقس يقال لقد سبق ان
افتخر بنيله شرف مبايعه العقيد معمر
القذافي وفي الثوره على القذافي اصبح فتى
ليبيا الاغر الثائر على الديكتاتوريه ان
هذه الشرائح تؤكد الحبوب والوفاء للقائد
وتؤكد ان الوطن غالي وانه استقرار هذا
الوطن المسؤوليه تاريخيه عندما كان الحرب
مجددا ايام القذافي
استمع لاي شيء ولن يستطيع ايا كان ان يوجه
لي اي تعليمات عقيله صالح ذهب الى دمشق
استقبله بشار الاسد فصار عقيل بعثيا عاد
هذا الاسبوع الى ليبيا زاره اعضاء الهيئه
الوطنيه لمشايخ واعيان ليبيا فلم يدعهم
يغادروا مجلسه دون هديه فاقترح ان تسند
اليهم مهمه اختيار رئيس البلاد فهل اذا
زاره منتخب الكره الليبي مثلا سيكلفه
بانتخاب مفتي ليبيا
[موسيقى]
يجتمع ويقولوا حتى مره يقولوا بكره
اخيرا مسنه فلسطينيه تقود افتراضيا طائره
لبضع دقائق بمساعده من القبطان الاردني
امنه بان تحلق فوق القدس المحتله وفوق
نابلس وكل فلسطين
روحي سبحي عليهم روحي
[موسيقى]
ختاما كان والدات طفل مرتان يحرصان كل عام
على مرافقته في القطار الى قريه جدته
ليقضي عندها عطله الصيف ثم يعودان هما الى
المدينه بعد طلب الطفل من والديه اي يستقل
القطار وحيدا هذه السنه لانه كبر
وفقا بعد نقاش وودعه في محطه الانطلاق
وهناك اقترب منه والده دس بطاقه في جيبه
وهمس في اذنه اذا شعرت خلال الرحله بالخوف
او التعب افتح هذه البطاقه ففيها ما يريحك
جلس مرتام وحيدا دون اهله لاول مره في
القطاع فشعر بعد دقائق بالارتباك من نظرات
الناس الغريبه اليه تقوقع على كرسيه ثم
ابتلت عيناه بالدموع في تلك اللحظه تذكر
بطاقه ابيه سحبها من جيبه ليقرا فيها يا
ولدي الحبيب انا في المقصوره الاخيره من
القطع
الى اللقاء ابويا
الحليم
ابويا الغالي
سندي وروحي
ونجمي العالي
ابويا حبيبي
وعشق دلالي
اضحي بكل شي بس يبقى قبالي
[موسيقى]